Hi everybody is Charlie we've got to break
down this Witcher teaser
everybody's having flashbacks to a whole
bunch of other projects because he
doesn't have the beard right now I
wonder if they're just going to have him
grow it over time so there's a couple
Easter eggs in here that's why I
attached that Witcher 2 clip at the
beginning with him taking the potion
before he rides into battle to take
another job potions of all kinds very
big in The Witcher lore so if you're
brand new to the channel I think what
I'll do is a giveaway for the book
series all you have to do to enter that
is be a subscriber and leave a Witcher
related comment on the video the reason
why the book series is important is
because they're basing the series on the
original novels not on the video games
the video games are a sequel to the
books and I think based on the age of
ciri during this like they've announced
who the main cast is I think we have a
pretty good idea where they're picking
this story up so we'll start with a cast
that I'll talk about the story because
obviously we have to process Henry
Capital I think for the most part it'll
be fine like Henry Cavill great actor he
can pull it off as long as they tweak
that wig beard situation because it does
look a little bit like Legolas from Lord
of the Rings right now but if you
remember part of the other reason why I
attached that clip to the beginning of
this is because his beard isn't very
prominent during that most of the people
watching this probably haven't read the
novels and in the novels he does not
have the beard so they're actually being
more authentic to the original story but
it's a very common problem because you
have this huge video game series and
everybody remembers The Witcher 3 and he
had a beard during that so they just
assume he always has a beard so when
henry cavill walks in and starts
slugging his potions down they're like
why doesn't he have a beard what's going
on
this will be multiple seasons so no
worries maybe the beard will evolve like
Rick Grimes beard on The Walking Dead
and he'd even evolved during the game
series but if you haven't seen they've
actually been posting more behind the
scenes this is actually the showrunner
posting where they're filming right now
this looks like it's care more in and
this is kind of the area where he's been
training in what Henry Cavill has
affectionately called
witcher school from a production
standpoint because while he can probably
pull some of the stuff off there's all
kinds of crazy stunts he has to learn to
use both of his swords he has to start
working with the horses that they're
going to be doubling for roche they've
actually found all those yet but
obviously they're going to reveal their
main character first I don't think
they've been filming for that long but
for the past couple of
henry cavill has been in boot camp for
the school of the wolf so I wouldn't be
surprised if the scenes that they're
filming here are really at care more and
then once they've revealed the actual
costumes and looks for the other main
characters like ciri yennefer they'll
probably reveal care more Han and some
of the other big locations but obviously
that'll probably only happen once they
start moving the production around as of
right now they've cast obviously Henry
cavils Geralt of Rivia they've cast
roached the horse because probably the
next most important character next to
gana for ciri but they've cast yennefer
they've cast ciri Triss Merigold
jet-skier sabrina and freeing gila they
have not announced who's playing Emperor
Amir or village forts because obviously
he's going to wind up being the big bat of
the series because it does seem like
they're starting with the beginning of
the novels they could either start
sometime during sword of Destiny which
is sort of a prequel to the original
main novels which introduces you to
everyone is the first introduction of
Ciri in the story or they could start
with blood elves which was originally
the first novel in the series before
they wrote the prequels
it's like George RR Martin's Song of Ice
and Fire series where it starts with the
first book Game of Thrones but then
publishes a prequel book like say fire
and blood which is coming out later this
month which details events before what
happened during the original main series
most of you are probably familiar with
the backstories of all the main
characters but here's a quick rundown if
you haven't read the novels with the
exception of Ciri who's a child Geralt
has had relationships with all the women
that I just named but yennefer is his
true love she was a high ranking member
in the brotherhood of sorcerers a royal
adviser very powerful sorceress but very
powerful politically in the way that
it's hard to trust a lot of magic users
because they will so much power there is
this sort of evil connotation to the
Conclave of mages so the way that they
sort of position her is as being
politically opposed to some of the ideas
that they have and tried to take
advantage of ciri
so obviously Geralt yennefer all the
other main cast members want to help and
protect ciri because she's supposed to
be part of this big prophecy that
village for it's has which will probably
be the main arc of the series however
many seasons that it runs
wrong footwork get down what is it what
do you think all right take off the
blindfold you've got work to do your
reflexes are still slow maybe for a
Witcher think drowners or Stricker's
we'll go easy on you because you haven't
undergone the mutations
Triss Merigold another powerful
sorceress who is a really great friend
to yennefer as well as had a
relationship with Geralt but she's part
of a slightly different organization
within the greater body of mages within
the kingdom fran gila is another
sorceress that was part of the same
organisation as Triss Merigold she also
had a relationship with Geralt at one
point most of you are probably familiar
with Ciri
she's Emperor Emhyr's daughter she's a
princess heir to the Empire of nilfgaard
but also a Witcher and training the
Geralt takes under his wing so he
becomes more of a father figure to her
than her true father Emperor Amir
cirilla Fiona Ellen Rhiannon queen of
sintra princess of brood and duchess of
certain eras to in Assad's Gaelic and in
his son Skellig and suzerain of etre and
Aviara get used to it before long every
soul from milk God to the Dragon
Mountains will kneel before you I did
not expect you to keep your word with
you just Gear's one of Geralt longtime
personal best friends he's a womanizer
they use him for a lot of comedy so I'm
assuming they're going to use him in the
same way to balance the group out during
the main series we're like Henry cavils
Geralt character tends to be a little
more serious he has a sense of humor but
he's not a character that spends a lot
of time telling jokes so usually you
need other characters around to lighten
the mood maou sac is a druid who helps
save Geralt life when he was a little a
kid so he's become a more prominent
figure in his life but also becomes a
much bigger figure in present-day
sabrina is another sorceress this a
member of yennefer organization and
serves as something of a foil for her
character more of a rival for yennefer
herself but she is pretty fun so they're
just kind of gives you an overview of
who the initial
main cast is going to be hopefully we'll
find out real soon who's playing Emperor
mere who's going to be playing village
forts but I'm not expecting them to
announce that until they start actually
getting ready to fill in those scenes
with those characters let me know in the
comments what do you guys think about
all this obviously there'll be more
frequent Witcher videos as we get more
information about the TV series I will
do episode videos of course because they
just started filming I'm expecting the
series to drop around this time next
year usually takes about a year to turn
series like this around and it is going
to premiere during 2019 there was a
brand new game of Thrones previews that
just dropped I'll do a breakdown of that
next that should be up in the next
couple of hours while you wait for
everything click here for more brand new
Game of Thrones and click here to learn
about the new Avengers 4 spin-off TV
series with Winter Soldier thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight!